it is time for this week's pet project
amy lee joins us from the nspca
and you have someone there who needs a
good safe home of cutie too
i mean look at how cute this little girl
her name is baby girl and she's
the sweetest little 10 year old cheatsu
she's
super super loving i'm just pretty
spunky for a 10 year old girl but
she's just mellow and calm and she's
just
so gentle and sweet she'd be wonderful
for a you know just a calm household
mature kids who know how to be gentle
um she's okay with other dogs that are
nice so we'd certainly do a meet and
greet at the shelter but
this little girl needs a home and look
how cute she is how old is baby girl
she's 10 years old okay and we came in
with some pretty bad dental and nevada
spca um
took care of all her dental needs so
she's just good and ready to go
with her but that's it yeah and smaller
dogs have a longer lifespan too
they tend to yeah the smaller dogs
certainly do you know like i said she's
she's we took care of all her medical
her dental so she's ready to find a
loving home with a really great family
and she's so deserving of it
and you guys love it when families
actually come there and visit with the
animals bring their kids bring
even their other pets to see if it gels
absolutely when you make an appointment
so we don't do walk-ins but when you
make an appointment yes if you have a
pet and
you're looking at a dog that is friendly
with other dogs yes bring your dog in we
want to make sure that
that it's a good match but we love it we
love hearing those stories of those
families that adopt from us and they
send us these really wonderful updates
um so we love doing that and i'd love to
hear that
for this little girl i know during
quarantine so many people adopted
animals
is that still the case are people still
adopting at a good pace
we're still yes i mean there's always a
need and you know it's
dogs and cats always are coming in and
out of our doors so it's always kind of
a cycle with with us
but um yeah i mean we and how can you
not want a dog in your family
he's so sweet she's so great i love her
i love her
i love the work you guys do thanks for
everything you're doing there amy lee
and the nspca appreciate it very much
if you're interested in adopting a pet
you can go to nevadaspca.org or call
them at that phone number
702-873-7722